say you've got a vision the next big IOT
device that are revolutionized the way
people interact with all of their
household appliances with your new IOT
device let's call it smart fridge
connected refrigerators will be able to
predict when foods will go stale and
even automatically reorder those items
directly from a grocer to keep the stock
up to date it's all flawless and you
know exactly what it'll do and who needs
it
but once you get that product in the
hands of millions no billions how will
you handle the vast amounts of data
that's gonna come pouring in have you
figured out how you're gonna collect
process and analyze all of your IOT data
you may want to consider using cloud IOT
core cloud IOT core is a fully managed
service that allows you to easily and
securely connect manage and ingest data
from millions of globally dispersed
devices how does it work
let's head over to quick labs in the lab
building an IOT analytics pipeline and
Google cloud platform you'll learn how
to ingest the stream of information from
cloud IOT core using cloud pub/sub
process all that IOT data using cloud
dataflow connect and manage mqtt based
devices using cloud IOT core and for the
purposes of this lab we're using
simulated devices lastly you'll be able
to analyze all of that IOT data using
Google bigquery and you can use your IOT
data stream for things like advanced
analytics visualizations and even
machine learning which is gonna help you
improve operational efficiency
anticipate problems and build rich
models that'll help you better describe
and optimize your business the lab will
take you less than an hour to complete
and it'll give you an opportunity to see
if cloud IOT core is gonna be a good fit
for smart fridge quick labs is an online
hands-on lab library with more than 150
labs on every cloud topic ranging from
introductory to guru level each lab will
help you learn a new skill in about an
hour using google cloud when you're
ready
use the link below to take the lab that
we just went through today and you're
ready to sign up for GCP look for that
link below and you can apply a $300
credit to your account today I'll be
responding to requests from Dan Pham
from one of our previous episodes dan
writes in and says great video for
kubernetes newbies and a nice segue into
how you can run all of your apps on GCP
I'd love to see some more customer
success stories about companies who are
using a micro service architecture
instead of traditional monolithic stacks
definitely thanks for writing them down
we have many customers too
is using Google cloud and there on our
Google cloud customer page there you can
discover why the world's most innovative
organizations are choosing to run their
applications on Google cloud a customer
story that I like and you can check out
is dolphin technologies and they say we
move to a docker eyes container based
micro services architecture with Google
kubernetes engine in just three months
that really paid off for us instead of
worrying that our systems are up we know
that they're up no question and if you
have a question or comment for us let us
know in the comment section below
[Music]